- [Voiceover] So let's revisit a scenario
that we have seen in several videos,
especially the last video,
where we tried to find this
neutral frame of reference.
Let's say we're in spaceship A.
We are in an inertial frame of reference.
And let's say right at time equal zero
in our frame of reference,
spaceship B is exactly where we are,
but it's traveling in
the positive x-direction
at eight tenths the speed of light.
We've already seen that we can overlay
the spacetime diagrams for each of these
frames of reference.
If we do our axes,
the x is one direction of spacetime
that we associate with
the x-direction of space
and then the ct, this vertical axis,
this is another direction of spacetime
that we perceive as the passage of time.
Well, you can then overlay
B's frame of reference,
and you kind of have these skewed axes.
And you could look at a change in time.
So for example, if you were to compare
the event right when B passes us up to
let's say some amount of time later,
some amount of, so let's
say this right over there
is the change in ct.
In our frame of reference,
these two events are happening
at the exact same place.
They're just separated,
in our frame of reference,
we would perceive them as
being separated by time.
But if you want to say, well how much time
seems to separate these events
in B's frame of reference?
Well then, you would wanna go
parallel to the x prime axis.
We're viewing B's frame of reference
as a primed frame of reference
and see where we intersect the ct prime,
the ct prime axis.
So this is our change in ct
while this is our change in ct,
this looks like our change in ct prime.
And it looks longer
but we have to remember
that we haven't scaled these things.
And actually the scales change
depending on the relative velocities.
But we can actually verify algebraically
that our change in ct
prime is going to be larger
than our change in ct.
And we just have to look
at Lorentz transformations
to realize that.
So our change in ct prime is going to be
equal to the Lorentz factor
times our change in ct
minus beta times our change in x.
We've seen that multiple times before.
Well our change in x,
our change in x is zero.
It looks stationary in
our frame of reference
so that term is zero.
So our change in ct prime
is going to be equal
to the Lorentz factor times,
I don't have to use this
parentheses anymore,
times our change in ct.
And our Lorentz factor is
going to be greater than one.
I could actually calculate
that, let's do it.
So the Lorentz factor,
the Lorentz factor here.
So gamma is going to be equal to one
over the square root of one minus,
well B's relative velocity so 0.8c
over the speed of light squared.
Well what is this going to simplify to?
The c's cancel out.
0.8 squared is 0.64.
One minus that is 0.36.
This is going to be,
and then you take the square root of that,
that's going to be one over 0.6
which is equal to one over six tenths
which is the same thing as 10 over six
which is equal to the
same thing as five thirds
which is equal to one and two thirds.
So you can see our change in ct prime
is going to be one and two thirds
times the change in ct.
Now you might wanna just say,
well do these two look
like one and two thirds?
And it might look a little bit like that
the way I draw it, but you can't just
look at it purely on,
you can't just take a
ruler for this length
and a ruler for this length
because the scales are different
and I haven't marked off the scales.
Well this at least helps us visualize.
But let's think about
the other way around.
Let's imagine the change in ct prime
between right where the spaceships pass by
and a little bit later.
Now, I'll do this in a different color
'cause this is actually a
different event in spacetime
than the one that we were
focusing on right now.
And we're gonna be viewing it
from B's frame of reference
so that's our change in ct prime.
But what is going to be our change in ct?
Well, to think about it,
we could go parallel to the x-axis,
the x-axis right over
there, so you'll parallel,
parallel to the x-axis and
you get right over there
and so our change in ct
looks like it's more.
And once again, we can
algebraically verify it
by really doing the same thing.
Our change in ct is going
to be equal to gamma
times our change in ct prime
minus beta times delta x prime.
And if you were to actually,
if we actually did have
a change in x prime here,
the beta, the velocity now
has a different direction
so it would all be the negative
but our change in x prime
from B's point of view,
these two events are
happening in the same place
so our change in x prime is zero.
So you have change in ct is
equal to gamma times change,
once again I don't need my parentheses,
times change in ct prime.
And it's going to be the same gamma
because remember, we're taking v over c
and so whether it's
either v or negative v,
when you square it, it gets the same value
so once again, gamma is going
to be one and two thirds.
So it's going to be one and two thirds.
So it seems a little bit strange.
You know, I have some passage of time
in my frame of reference where it looks,
you know, it's something
that looks stationary,
two events that look
like they're happening
in the same place but one after another.
It looks like their change in time,
it takes longer for those
two events to happen
in the ct prime in the
moving frame of reference.
But then, if we have some event
that looks stationary in
B's frame of reference
and they're separated
by a change in ct prime,
it looks like the change in
ct between those two events
is even larger.
So it looks like this
somewhat bizarre phenomenon.
And to help us reconcile these
and to visualize a little bit better,
actually even to be able
to put ct and ct prime
on the same scale,
we can look for this
neutral frame of reference
which we did in actually
the last video I made.
I don't know if it's the
last video you've seen.
Or we could say look, if A and B
are travelling with a
relative velocity of 0.8
times of the speed of light
relative to each other,
B is travelling 0.8c in
the positive x direction
relative to a stationary A
or A is travelling 0.8c in
the negative x direction
relative to a stationary B.
You can find a frame of reference
where A and B were in
that frame of reference
to a stationary observer
in that frame of reference,
A and B are both travelling outwards
at half the speed of light.
And we figured that out where we
did those videos on a
neutral frame of reference.
And what's neat about that
is if you make what looks like
a Minkowski spacetime diagram
in that neutral frame of reference
then the ct and ct prime, A
and B's frame of references,
get equally skewed to the, you know,
if you think about the time
axis to the left and the right.
And since they're equally skewed,
the time dilation relative
to this rest frame
is the scaling is going to be the same.
So we could put both of these on,
both of these on the same scale.
And you could see that this
neutral frame of reference,
this ct prime prime frame of reference,
I drew them over here,
that if you look at either of
A or B's frame of reference,
they're going to be in between
A and B's frame of reference.
But here it's the neutral one.
It's the one where we're drawing the time
or we're drawing the two
axes being perpendicular
to each other.
And now if you look at these two events,
so if you look at this first event,
where you have our delta ct,
so you look at this first event
where you have a delta in ct between
right when the spaceships
pass and right over there.
You see that if you were to look at that,
if you were to look at
the ct prime coordinate
for that event, when you go
parallel to the x prime axis,
you get right over there.
So this is, that is
your change in ct prime.
And likewise, if you have that other event
that I drew in that blue-green
color, right over here.
And this is your change in ct prime.
This is your change in ct prime,
well then if you think of it
from A's frame of reference,
well we just follow the
x-axis not the x prime.
We go parallel to it.
We end up right over there.
Now what's really interesting about this,
what's really interesting about this
is from A's frame of reference,
the yellow event happens
before the blue event.
But in B's frame of
reference, the blue event
happens before the yellow event.
So really, really, really
fascinating things going on
but what I really like about this diagram
is that A and B's frame of reference
are going to have the same scale
since they're both equally
skewed to the left and the right
if we're thinking about the time axis.
And this type of diagram
is called a Loedel diagram.
Loedel, Loedel diagram which is really
a variation of a Minkowski diagram
but it lets us really
appreciate the symmetry
between these frames of reference.